we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P this really
cracked me up when I heard it
um yesterday we played this clip of my
pillow Mike Lindell saying he found out
that a supposedly 850 year old person
voted uh in the 2020 election that's
part of the fraud here is a caller
making a similar point it's a joke but
they do it beautifully
hey David this is uh Stuart from
Wisconsin by the way even the detail of
pronouncing Wisconsin Wisconsin the way
Mike pillow did this is a perfect
voicemail down to the Last Detail I have
you know that I know two people who won
the 753 years old and the other is 827
years old long Kettering and Johnny
Hopkins and they used to play that [ __ ]
every day these guys voted can you
imagine
it's crazy yeah 753 year olds are out
there voting it's it's wild wild times
um I'm glad that essentially everybody
in my audience seems to have realized
the absurdity of uh of Mike pillow's
claims we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today as many of you know uh gas
powered leaf blowers I believe are the
devil's work I believe they are the mark
of the beast quite frankly California is
working to ban gas-powered leaf blowers
and lawn mowers their motivations may be
environmental minor sound pollution
oriented we will talk about that also
interest in the flu shot this season is
not very high I got my flu shot we will
talk about why interest seems to not be
very high on today's bonus show and
lastly we have the first ever approval
for a malaria vaccine
huge we'll talk about the implications
and more on today's bonus show sign up
at joinpakman.com you'll get instant
access to the world famous bonus show
I'll see you then or otherwise we'll be
back with a new show tomorrow